[Music]
we all got olympic fever
what
you're just randomly yelling usa but you
know
and what was said it was about an eighth
of them
we have a lot of people here from other
countries clearly
i know it was a great day at the
olympics though i'm enjoying it i really
am but tough day for the romney family
did you know this the romneys have a
horse competing in the olympics
yeah
yeah this is true ann romney's horse
failed to win a medal in the dressage
event today
yeah which is a shame because if there's
one thing that family needs it's more
gold
it's so sad to me i know it would have
been it would have been fun if it
bronzed just to see ann go like
what's that ew bronze silver uh
ann romney's olympic horse is named
rafalka
yeah when asked why she picked rofalco
she said i needed a silly name that no
one's ever heard of before and mitt was
taken
that's a true story
that's a true story
that's
a true story
that's my new tagline for every joke
that's a true story
do that with my thumb uh olympic
champion ryan lochte says yeah
that's right ladies and that guy
olympic champion ryan lochte says the
best way to pick up a woman is to wink
at her
yeah
this was in an article entitled things
that only work for ryan lochte
i've tried winking many times i get
pepper sprayed
that's a true story
that's just true
speaking of swimming i couldn't believe
this a former u.s olympic swimmer in an
interview said that nearly all elite
competitive swimmers pee in the pool
regularly
yeah
so apparently i am an elite competitive
[Applause]
don't even want to know what that means
i'm not sure
check this out many people are in an
uproar about a rumor that the iphone 5
is gonna cost eight hundred dollars
yeah
yeah apparently the iphone 5 is just an
iphone 4 with 500 taped to the back
which to me actually makes it sound kind
of worthwhile sure
there's a nerd section that got real mad
up here about that
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
now they're leaving
packing up their chest sets and leaving
and in mexico kim kardashian and kanye
west went ziplining with the creator of
girls gone wild
yeah unfortunately no one was harmed
[Applause]
[Music]